So, I think we're on June the 9th, 1922. Is that correct?
Jesus wants to rest in the soul. Everything in Him is merciful love.
As I was in my usual state, my beloved Jesus would come very often.
And sometimes he would lean his head upon mine telling me,
"My daughter, I need rest." And she's usually complaining that he's not coming.
This time he's coming very often, so she's happy.
The uncreated intelligence, watch this, wants to rest in the created intelligence.
But in order to find true rest, I should find in your intelligence all the glory
and the contentment which all other intelligences should give me.
Therefore, my will wants to expand your capacity to be able to find this rest.
No, I'm not content if my will does not place in you all that the others should give me.
And then he seemed to breathe over my intelligence,
and it remained as though chained by many threads of light.
For as many created minds as came out of the hands of the Creator, we say past, present and future.
At each thread of light, he said, "I'm sorry."
And each thread of light said, "Glory, gratitude, honor to my God, thrice holy."
And Jesus said, "Ah, yes, now I can rest.
I find the requital of the intelligence of creation.
The created mind is fused with the uncreated mind."
That is the great mystery of the fusing, the great mystery.
So the first thing is the uncreated intelligence resting in the created intelligence.
Now the second one is the heart, that's the next paragraph.
"Afterward he leaned his head upon my heart,
and it seemed that he could not find complete rest.
So he placed his mouth over my heart and breathed it in it."
That's John 20, 22 to 23, when Jesus breathed on the apostles
and the church became a living being.
And also you have Genesis 2, 7.
And Genesis 2, 7, Adam became a living being once the breath of God was breathed upon him.
"At each breath my heart became larger, and he had a daughter I am determined to rest.
Therefore I want to breathe into your heart so much as to place in it all the love
which all the rest of creation should give to me."
Now look how big the heart has to be.
It has to be able to hold the love that all the rest of creation should have.
"My rest cannot be perfect if I do not find the requital of the love
that came out from me. Therefore I want to find in this heart the love
that all that's your past, present and future should give to me."
"My volition will make this project in you and your heart will have a note for everyone."
That's just one of the key things about the divine will, spirituality, and that is it's universal.
It's not individual, it's universal. You pray for all souls past, present, and future all the time.
So it has a note for everyone which says to me love.
So from somebody living in the divine will, there's love going to the Creator for everyone.
"Then he leaned his head on my heart again and he rested. How beautiful it was to see Jesus resting.
And then he disappeared and he came back and he wanted to rest on my hands and then on my shoulder.
So the intellect was first, the heart was second, the hands representing your work,
and the shoulder, which is rather interesting, usually represents the burdens you carry.
It seems that he wanted to see whether all of my person was fit to let him rest.
Afterwards he added, "My beloved, how much love I feel for you. All the love which I should give
to others and which they refuse, I concentrate in you." Sometimes at the beginning of the divine
will journey, people ask, "Well, is there anything in it for us?" And we're supposed to give everything
completely unselfishly, but in actual fact what others don't receive, he gives to you anyway.
So all the love that I should give to others and which they refuse, I concentrate in you.
Therefore one of the key signs that we're growing in divine will is that we're growing in love.
"In you I hear the echo of my creation word. Let us make man in our own image and likeness."
That's Genesis 1.27.
And I see the fulfillment of it. "Our will alone will make man return to its first origin."
It has to be divine intervention as you know. "Our will will cast all the divine impressions
into the human will and overwhelming one will within the other. It will carry him on its wings."
That's Exodus 19.4. "I carry you on eagles wings all the way to this place."
"It will carry him on its wings into the arms of the Creator."
"Not as ugly as sin rendered him, but as pure, beautiful and similar to his Creator."
That's Matthew 5.8. "Only the pure and heart see God."
Therefore I want you to receive all the impressions of my will into yours
so that heaven and earth may recognize nothing but the divine will acting in you.
Notice heaven and earth by which they will feel as though overwhelmed
and all will receive the good of the divine operating in the creature.
Therefore be ready in everything and be faithful to me. So notice this has to be a 100% total self-giving
otherwise it doesn't work. That's your Deuteronomy 6.4 to 10. And the Lord has to do this conquering
in each one. He started with Louisa and that's how he will gradually get to the whole human race.
After this he came back but all afflicted and he told me, "I feel sad when they think I am
severe." This is human beings judging Jesus and God wrongly and therefore they make the excuse
to stay aloof from him. And what Jesus met not only in his own day but you'll even meet it even
today that they will accuse God of being the God of Sinai and they will not accept that the
incarnation actually changed everything so that the era of wrath which was from the time of Moses
to the time of Christ was changed to the era of merciful love from the time of Christ.
And they still want to accuse God of being the God of Sinai. I feel sad when they, that human
beings say that I am severe, that's the God of Sinai and that I make more use of justice than
of mercy. Now when Jesus says they, he's talking about the people in 1922 reacting to the chastisments
that are going on, we're very quick to accuse God of being very severe. An example I would give you
is that a child in school being corrected by a teacher and they go home and says, "The teacher
has it in for me." I didn't need any correction at all, I'm absolutely perfect but the teacher
has it in for me. So the person who needs to do the correction is accused of being very severe.
So that's the Old Testament, the God of Sinai thing. They behave with me as if I were to strike
them at each circumstance, not that he has waited hundreds and hundreds of years with great patience,
or how dishonored I feel by these ones. In fact, this leads them to remain a due distance from me
and one who is distant cannot receive the infusion of my love, naturally enough, you're not close enough.
And while they are the ones who do not love me, they think that I am severe and almost a being
that strikes fear. Well, if you remember the way some of us were reared, you know,
pre-stomping the altar and telling us we were going to hell if you were two minutes late from
us. Well, that was a completely wrong image of God saying that God was so severe that he would
strike you for something minor. You know what I mean? That's the kind of thing that's been spoken
about here. And the people, Jesus says, the people who are giving this type of reaction to him
are also keeping themselves at a distance from him because you don't really come close to somebody
who is over severe, do you? And while they are the ones who do not love me, they think that I am
severe and almost a being that strikes fear. While by just taking a look at my life, they can but
notice that I only did one act of justice. That was when in order to defend the house of my father,
I took the ropes and snapped them to the right and to the left to drive out the profanators.
Now you know how he cleansed the temple. It's not explained anywhere else. I snapped the ropes to
the right and the left. You see it? That's John 2 14 to 25. He cleansed the temple twice, one at
the beginning and the other at the end of his ministry. But the beginning one is in John 2.
I took the ropes and snapped them to the left and to the right to drive out the profanators.
All the rest was only mercy. Mercy, my conception, my birth, my words, my works, my steps, the blood
I shed, my pains, everything in me was merciful love and yet they fear me. While they should fear
themselves more than me. So beside that, I want to put Luke 23, 28, where Jesus told the women of
Jerusalem to worry about themselves and their children. Not about him. Okay.
So June the 11th, 1922, the natural life symbolizes the spiritual life. Now I've told you many times
that the Lord told me many years ago, there's almost nothing in the spiritual life that you can't
illustrate from family life. Either the relationship of the spouses or their relationship with their
children. And I've never found, I was short of an illustration once I would go to the family.
Okay. He had to tell me because I wasn't married, you see. And I had left home when I was 12, so I
don't remember family life. So he says that the natural life symbolizes the spiritual life.
I was thinking to myself, how is it that the spiritual life also undergoes so many changes?
Well, of course, if you're growing, you undergo many changes. While one is convinced that this
will be his life, then when he least expects it, he is flung somewhere else, dragging along who
knows how many painful consequences which make his heart bleed. One can say that because of the
many changes one undergoes, it is a continuous martyrdom. And my sweet Jesus, moving in my
interior told me my daughter, indeed, the spiritual life must be a continuous martyrdom. Why? Because
the ego has to die. The self has to die and divine love has to be born. And that's the biggest
death we can have because it must be similar to the first and the greatest of the martyrs,
which is myself. And if it were not so, it cannot be truly called spiritual life, but larva and the
shadow of it. Then it is necessary that it undergoes various changes. This in order to make it reach
the proper stature and render it noble, beautiful and perfect. If the human nature itself, which is
less important undergoes who knows how many changes in order to reach the proper stature,
much more so this happens in the spiritual life, which is more important than the natural life
and superior to it. Even more, the natural life symbolizes the spiritual life. And for people who
haven't studied biology or going to get a biology lesson in the next paragraph, okay, observe how
many changes does the natural life go through? It is conceived inside the maternal womb and there
it remains for as long as nine months in order to form the little body. And when it is formed,
it is forced to come out. If it wanted to remain inside, it would die because it would lack the
space to grow and so it would suffocate jeopardizing its life and that of the mother. Now, if this
conception were formed outside of the maternal womb, who would provide the blood and the heat
to form the little body? Well, modern scientists can tell you they can do it. Moreover, since the
members are extremely tender, the air itself would kill it. Interesting, isn't it? How much care is
not needed with the little newborn? Heat, cold, and even the constraints of the maternal womb can
be deadly for him. And therefore, swaddling, clothes, cradle, milk, if one wanted to give
him some other food, the little one would not know how to chew it. And so his life would be put in
danger. But then the time also comes when he becomes capable of taking food and the swaddling
clothes are removed and he learns to take a few steps. Do you see we're still at the infancy and
still there are many changes? Okay. Hope it doesn't go the whole way. Now, what would you say if this
little one seeing himself placed on the ground so as to take the first step in fear of being snatched
from the arms of his mother, screamed, cried, and refused to have any of it? Many of them do,
don't they? One would feel sorry for him because in the arms of the mother, he would never become a
man without motion. He would not become strong or developed. Okay. So the next paragraph,
now we come to the true spiritual life. Now let us come to the true spiritual life. It is conceived
in my womb, my blood, my love, and my breath to form it. Okay. The breath, of course, is the Holy
Spirit. Then I feed it at my breast. That's the Holy Eucharist and the word of God is the food.
I swaddle it with my graces and then I continue by making it walk with my truths. However,
my design is not to form a child to play with, but a copy fully similar to myself. That's Romans
829 that were made in the image of the son. So this is why changes occur for nothing other than
to let it reach a mature age and give it all those privileges and prerogatives which true
spiritual life contains. Otherwise, it would remain like a baby in swaddling clothes who,
instead of forming my honor and glory, would form my sorrow and dishonor. But how many are
those who remain only newborn and are at most swaddled. So what he's saying is many, many people
do not let their spiritual life grow at all. They just allow maybe one or two things to happen
and then it must be like that always. I've always been like this. You know what I mean? It's sure
signed they're not growing. Look at the last line. Very few are those who work together with me
to become a copy of myself. That's a very important statement. So to that, I want to add something
of St. John of the Cross. St. John of the Cross says that even people who allow certain changes
to happen for them to grow spiritually, that the Lord gives you two major purifications in your life.
One is what he calls the purification of the senses and the other one is the purification of
the soul of the spirit. And a lot of people will actually endure the first purification. The second
one, no, because it's totally interior and they don't allow the Lord. They don't trust God enough
to let them do it. And so John of the Cross says that many people are like, I'm going to add
another image to John of the Cross. I like the climbers on Mount Everest. And Mount Everest is
covered with the stuff left behind when people have abandoned the three stops. The vast majority
got as far as stage one. Stage two is covered with all the litter of human beings who barely nearly
got there, dropped all their baggage and came back. Stage three is even more littered. And John of
the Cross says the greatest tragedy in the spiritual life are the people who stop about four meters
from the goal. The greatest tragedy in the spiritual life. That's what Jesus is referring to here.
Very few are those who will work with me to become a copy of myself, because to become a copy of
Jesus, the old nature has got to go. And the new nature, as St. Paul says, we've got to become a
whole new person in Christ. Okay. So June the 15th, 1922, the divine will is the central point of the
life of Jesus and of the soul who lives in it. So the divine will has to be utterly central.
The divine heartbeat is the little cell of the soul who lives in the divine will. Think of yourself
now as a tiny little cell inside of the heart of God. Isn't that fantastic? And harmonizes everything
with the creature. Continue in my usual state. I was thinking about the holy will of God. And while
I was fusing myself in it, my beloved Jesus told me, my daughter, my eternal will was the central
point of my life. Now, I'm going to give you a whole lot of scriptures. And it's the summary of
John's gospel. I've given to them, given them to you before, but you don't probably won't know
where you've written them. Okay. This is a summary of John's gospel. John for 30.
Just put John and then just put the numbers down. John for 30, 534.
638. 828 and 55. 828, 855. 1029 and 38.
1250 and 1431. Now, if you go through these statements, Jesus will say, I only came to do
the will of my father. The father and I are one. I only reveal what my father tells me to reveal.
I only teach what my father tells me to teach. And he ends up in 1431 by saying, I want the world
to know that I love the father. And therefore, I do exactly what my father tells me. And it's
this exact obedience that is being demanded of Louisa as well. Okay, this is exact obedience.
So my eternal will was the central point of my life. From the first act of my conception,
up to my last breath, it preceded me, it accompanied me, becoming the life of my act,
and it followed me in closing my act in the eternal sphere of my will, from which it could
find no way out. And since my eternal will was immense, there was not one point which it would
not encircle nor generation that it would not dominate. Therefore, it was as though natural for
it to form my acts, natural for the divine will to form his acts, and to multiply them for all,
as if they were just for one alone. Okay, so there's the model for us that the divine will was the
absolute center of Jesus's life. All his acts were divine acts, absolutely everything. No matter
what he did, they were all divine acts. An individual can give only what he possesses.
As much power as he may contain, he cannot give more than he possesses. Now, my will possessed
the immensity, the power of the multiplication of acts into as many as it wanted. It possessed
the eternity into which it overwhelmed all things present and everyone, as in the beginning of all
things until the end. So the divine will has all power to accomplish everything at once.
And therefore, when we put our acts in the divine will, then they're entering into that divine
power, and they are multiplied for absolutely everybody. This is why, from the first moment of
my conception, the power of my will formed as many conceptions for as many creatures as would
come into existence. It multiplied my words, thoughts, works and steps and extended them from
the first to the last man, I say, from Adam to Zachary, A to Z. The power of the eternal volition
converted my blood, my pains into immense seas, of which all can avail themselves.
If it wasn't for the prodigy of the supreme will, my very redemption would have been individual,
circumscribed and only for a few generations. Why? Because it would have been limited to the human.
And so what he's showing you is that something that's limited to the human can have only a small
effect. If it's put into the divine, it becomes immense and eternal and for everybody. It's a
very good way of describing it there and letting us know how we've got to enter into every act of
his life. Now, my will has not changed. That's the problem with modern people. They think that
because they've changed that God's will should have changed, because they've abrogated the 10
commandments that God should abrogate the 10 commandments. And when we say that Christ is the
same yesterday, today and forever, which is the official teaching of the church, then they say
we're intolerant because we're not going along with them. So my will has not changed what it was,
it is and will be. That's why the word of God is just forever. More so, since I myself came upon
the earth and I came to tie once again the divine will to the human will. And for the soul who does
not escape from this tie and places herself at the mercy of the divine will, letting herself be
preceded, accompanied and followed. Now, this is very important. You see the before, during and
after the acts, preceded, accompanied and followed. That's actually very important. In closing her
act in my volition, that which happened to me happens to her. That means the acts become divine.
They're multiplied. They are applied to absolutely everybody as well.
If you look at that little statement again, letting herself be preceded, accompanied and
followed. The preceded, the church calls that Pervenian grace, grace given ahead of time.
A company then is the actual grace. And I don't know if they have a word for grace that does
a follow up. Okay. So the Pervenian grace, the actual grace and then the grace that follows up the
action. See, as you were fusing your thoughts, your words, your works, your reparations, your
little love in my will, I extended them. I multiplied them and they became an antidote for each thought,
each word, each work, reparation for each offense and love for each love that is due to me.
There's the statement about the acts. I think it's absolutely fantastic.
And if this does not happen, it is the fault of the human will. In other words, it hasn't
handed over to the divine, which not abandoning itself completely prey to the divine will. Now,
notice completely prey to the divine will, does not take everything nor can it give itself
to everyone. So that's the bit we've got. We're really careful about in doing our acts that we
really are consciously handing over to the Lord all the time. So when you don't do this completely,
it feels the sensations of what is human, which make it unhappy, circumcribe it,
impoverish it and render it incomplete. This is the reason for all my interest that you will live
life in mine and that you understand well what it means to live in it as much as it is possible
for the creature. Because if you do this, you will have obtained everything and will give me
everything. That's one of the VIP statements in the 36 volumes. Because if you do this,
you will have obtained everything and you will give me everything. There's nothing more to ask.
Once we've handed over this one thing that he's asking, which is our will. And we have to hand
it over all the time. So having said this, he disappeared. But later he came back again and
made himself seen all wounded. Those wounds formed many little cells in which Jesus called souls to
implose them to keep them safe. I said to him, my love, what about my little cell? Where is it?
So that I may enclose myself in it and never go out of it again. And Jesus said, my daughter,
for you, there are no little cells in my body. Because one who lives in my will cannot live in one
compartment of mine, but must live in the heartbeat of my heart. In other words, you live in the very
center of my being. The heart represents your whole being. The heartbeat is the center and the life
of the human body. If the heartbeat ceases, then life ceases. Now, St. Therese of Lesus came to
understand this as well. And so towards the end of her life, she said, I know what you called me to
that I am to be love in the heart of the church. Not only therefore am I lodged in your heart,
but I'm lodged in the heart of the church as well, the very center of the church. So naturally,
someone living in the divine will is also living in the highest place in the church.
And because we're a hierarchical church, you think highest place means somewhere in the hierarchy.
But when you're on the level of souls, that is not so. It's where you are relating
to God spiritually, is where you are in God's eyes. The external hierarchy is understood as
needed for the running of the church. Okay. So the heartbeat is the center and the life of the
human body. If the heartbeat ceases, life ceases. The heartbeat maintains the blood circulation,
the heat, the breathing, and therefore the strength and the activity of the members.
If the heartbeat is not regular, all the human faculties are in disorder. Even the intelligence
loses liveliness, ingenuity, and the fullness of the intellectual light. If the heartbeat is
not regular, I think you're talking about the heartbeat dysfunction there rather than just a
missed heartbeat. In fact, in creating man, I placed a special sound in his heart to which I bound
the eternal harmony in such a way that if the heartbeat is healthy, everything is harmony in
the creature. So if the heart is right, the whole thing is right. Okay. So he's going to continue on
this subject of harmony. Now, my will is like the heartbeat in the creature. If it palpitates
sanctity harmonizes and virtues harmonize, she harmonizes between heaven and earth.
Her harmony extends up to the sacrosanctranity. This is why for you, there is my heartbeat that
offers itself as a little cell in order to enclose you in it. And so that palpitating with one
single heartbeat, you may harmonize between heaven and earth. You may circulate in the past, in the
present and in the future and be present in everything. You circulating in me and I in you. Now, that's
John 14 21. And it's also John 15 9 as the father has loved me. So I have loved you. So you can see
that someone living in the divine will he's saying is in the very center of everything. That's going
to not only harmonize you, but harmonize the church and eventually harmonize the world with heaven,
heaven and earth harmonizing. So you can see that his plan is to regenerate the human race from the
center. Okay. So June the 19th, 1922, I have a VIP on this one. Every time the soul operates in
the divine will, she gives God the field or the space to release new beatitudes. In other words,
you stimulate the blessed Trinity to release new beatitudes and new contentment. Continue in my usual
state. I felt submerged in the supreme will of my sweet Jesus. It seemed to me that every little
act of mine done in the divine will made new contentment come out from the divine majesty.
And of course, the first two benefit from these new contentments are the saints in heaven.
And my beloved Jesus told me, my daughter, I possess such contentance, happiness and beatitudes
that I could give every new joys and beatitudes at every instant. So every time the soul
operates in my will, she gives me, we would say the opportunity to release new beatitudes and new
contentment, which I possess. And since my will is immense and invades everyone and everything,
as they come out, they flow over the soul who is operating in my divine will as the primary cause
for which the beatitudes are being released. And then they circulate in everyone. So these
beatitudes, first of all, flow over you if you're making the act and then over everybody else,
both in heaven and on earth. Therefore, as many times as you operate in my will,
so many more beatitudes and joys, do you make me release? And I feel the contentment of sharing
the joys I possess. Now, if you consider that all of us, I presume, are making acts all the time.
Okay. Try and imagine the amount of beatitudes and joys and everything that's being released
by the Lord with all of that and multiply it to infinity. It's incredible. It's an incredible
thing. It's much more powerful than we realize. So he says, "My will wants to release what it
possesses, but it keeps looking for one who will give it the occasion or the opportunity,
one who is disposed to receive, and one who prepares a little place in her soul,
in which to place these new contentments of mine." So if our souls are filled up with all kinds
of self stuff, there's no room for what he wants to give us. Okay. In one of the paintings of
Elizabeth Wang, she paints the soul as sort of a womb, and she shows the soul immediately after
receiving Holy Communion, and she has Jesus sitting on the side of it, looking rather puzzled,
because he has been received and there's no room for him. And in the soul is the soul of a good person.
Now, it's not the soul of a person abusing the sacrament. And inside in the soul, she shows
different boxes, tall ones and small ones and square ones and round ones and everything.
And it's merely junk that there isn't actually enough room for him. And she said that the Lord
told her to illustrate it and that good people would get the message. That it's just junk things.
You know the way we say, "I very clear out that room." It's not the only junk in it, you know.
That very often it's the junk of everyday life and how we react that actually stops us from
experiencing the fullness of divine will. So notice, I'll read that again. My will wants to release
what it possesses, but it keeps looking for one who would give it the occasion or the opportunity,
one who is disposed to receive, and one who prepares a little place in her soul in which
to place these new contentments of mine. So we have to make room for him.
Now, by wanting to do my will, the soul opens the doors of my volition and emptying herself of her
own volition. You see, if that's not happening, nothing's happening. If we're not on the not my
will, but I'm beyond platform, we're going over. She prepares a little place for me in which
to place my goods. And as she enters into my will to operate, she gives me the occasion
to release newbie attitudes from myself. Now notice new ones, not old ones in circulation.
Each one of us gives God an opportunity to do something new, which I think is beautiful.
So therefore I anxiously await that the soul come to operate in my volition in order to unleash
a new joy from myself and make myself known as the God that I am, who is never exhausted.
And to always has something to give to one who does my will. Is that magnificent?
And the thing is, we are usually not aware of what he's doing with us,
except that if you look back after a few years, you just notice you've changed.
Even you yourself have noticed that you've changed, or as Ebenezer Scrooge says,
I'm not the man I was. There's been a divine intervention. So June the 23rd, 1922, I have a VIP
on this one as well. One who is not completely empty of his own will cannot have a sure knowledge
of the will of God. The little word K-E-Y beside that, that's one of the keys that you can discern.
So if we're not getting what the divine will is about, then it means we're not giving our own will.
I was thinking to myself, Jesus says many things about his most holy will,
but it seems that he is not understood, even by the Confessors themselves. Now,
Louisa was having this problem immediately, naturally enough. They seem doubtful,
and in the face of a light so immense, they're neither illumined nor drawn to a love,
to love a will so lovable. Now, they're getting all this revelation through Louisa,
but they're giving a very skeptical response, which means they're not actually entering,
they're not actually doing it. The one who did it was canonized, wasn't he?
Now, while I was thinking of this, my beloved Jesus throwing his arm around my neck told me,
my daughter, don't be surprised. One who is not completely empty of his own will,
cannot have a sure knowledge of mine. This is the key to understanding it. Very important.
And for those of you who are teaching divine will, very, very important.
Because the human will forms the cloud between mine and his, and it's difficult to see through
a cloud. And it hinders the knowledge of the value and the effects which mine contains.
But in spite of this, they can't say it's not light. I love that, you know, because light does
come through a cloud. Even very black clouds, some light gets through. Okay. So,
see also the things which can be seen down here, that's on earth, are not understood by man.
So Jesus says, not only do they not understand my stuff, they don't even understand the stuff
that's around them. And who can ever tell how I created the sun or how much light and heat it
contains? Yet they see it and they enjoy its effects. It is with them all day and its heat and light
follow them everywhere. Yet with all this, they neither know nor can they tell it's height or the
light and the heat it possesses. And if anyone wanted to raise, raise himself in order to know
what the light would eclipse him and the heat would burn him up. So, man is forced to keep his eyes
low and to enjoy its light without being able to investigate it, contenting himself with saying,
well, it's the sun. Beside that, I want you to put Job, chapters 38 to 40. When Job and his three
companions had been going on and on and on about every theory that was going on at the time,
God got fed up with it and he intervened and he said to Job, where were you when I created the
morning? And where were you when I said to the sea thus far and no further? And he brought him
through this incredible journey through creation. And it was so incredible that Job said,
I repent and sackcloth and ashes. I'm the man who was talking rubbish. The others didn't repent
like that because they didn't see the same vision. Okay. So, not only do we not understand spiritual
things. The world itself is a mystery. Of course, as we're reading it, they've sent a probe to the
sun, you know, but they don't know if the sun will burn it off. We're going to see how far they
can get. So, if this happens with the sun, which can be seen and which I created for the natural
good of man, more so with the truths which contain all how much more light and heat than the sun
itself. Very important, especially the truths with regard to my will. This is why they've got to be
studied all the time and they've got to be learned and taught because they contain eternal effects,
goods and value. Who can ever measure all that the divine will contains? It would be as though
wanting to be eclipsed. It would be better for them to lower their foreheads. That means get a bit
of humility and enjoy the light which my truth brings, loving it and making that little light
which the human intelligence comprehends their own rather than putting it aside as something
that doesn't belong to them because they do not understand all the fullness of the light.
So, the Lord is saying there we need to have a little bit of humility to just accept what we can
and then as we grow more and more in the divine will then we'll be able to understand more and more.
So, they enjoy the light of the sun as much as they can although they do not understand it.
They make use of it in order to work and to walk and to look and all they long for daylight
so that its light may keep them company and live with them. But then my truths which are more than
light and make the sun of the day rise in the human minds and are neither regarded nor loved
nor longed for and are considered as a trifle. The comparison there is very interesting isn't it?
What sorrow Jesus said. However, when I see that they put my truths aside I put them aside. Warning,
warning, warning, warning. Put Romans chapter 1 where three times you're told and God abandons them
and God abandons them and God abandons them. So, the Lord is saying if you don't want to take this
seriously it's okay I'll go on to somebody else. So, we need to sort of pull up our socks and realize
if I don't take this seriously he's not going to take me seriously is he? He has lots of others
to go to. So, if they put my truths aside I put them aside and I allow my truths to follow their
course with souls who love them all the time he's looking for people who will love him and love
his word okay and and the sad thing is that if you look at Jesus in the days of his incarnation
the people who rejected him and did not love him and did not love his word and the rejection
turned into hatred and into killing him and then there was little people whom those people would
have despised and they had the humility to accept and love and be transformed. So, it's the same
principle okay. So, do you think that I have told you everything about the truths is only volume 14
of course he hasn't and the effects and the value that my truths contain make sure go to the left
won't you? Oh how many more suns I have to make rise and do not be surprised if you do not understand
everything be content with living from or out of this light it's enough just be content to do that
and it's a bit like Sam 1 3 1 you know the child is on its mother's lap and the child
will accept whatever the mother gives and will live on it and grow on it and be happy and then
the child comes to maturity at a later point so he's saying take what you can and so I say to people
who are studying these volumes if there's something there you really don't grasp even if someone
explains it and you still don't grasp but just move on don't let it trip you just move on
because it will eventually come to light because usually as you know goes back and explains
something from a slightly different angle to help you to get it. So, June the 26th 1922 isolation
and loneliness of Jesus in the midst of creature okay and there's a wonderful revelation in this
whole passage and it is that Jesus is lonely for us. That's the summary of what you're going to read
and I just think that is mind-blowing that Jesus is actually lonely for us he is love
and he's looking for our love. Continuing in my usual state my beloved Jesus came
and since I had been all contracted for a few days to the point of feeling incapable of motion
also she's stuck and the priest hasn't released her. Taking my hands and his he told me my daughter
let me lose you that means the priest hasn't been doing it. Now in the early volumes as you know
the priest did it all the time and placing himself close to me he put my arms on his shoulders telling
me now you are loosened cling to me for I have come to keep you company and to receive yours in
exchange that's Proverbs 8 31 God delights to be with the children of men. See I am God isolated
by creatures do you remember I think it's Genesis 4 I can't remember the verse Adam where are you
it was God looking for Adam okay. I live in their midst I am the life of each one of their acts
while they keep me as if I were not with them or how I cry over my loneliness I have had the same
lot as the sun while it lives in the midst of all with its light and heat and there's no
fecundity which does not come from it and with its heat it purifies the earth of so many filthy
things and its goods are incalculable which with magnanimity it makes the send upon all yet it lives
up high always alone while man ungrateful never sends a thank you to it or a sign of gratitude
in other words we take everything for granted that's the way I am alone always alone if you
take the aloneness of Jesus in the tabernacle you know we actually know he's there and we pay
no attention whatever and I am the light of every thought the sound of every word the motion of
every work the step of every foot and the beat of every heart because if the divine will doesn't
concur with us we can't do it isn't that right. Yet man ungrateful leaves me alone never says
a thank you to me and never and I love you see why he gets us to do the rounds so that we make up
for these voids for everybody so that's number one number two I'm isolated in his intelligence
because he uses the light that I give him for himself and perhaps even to offend me
the third one is I'm isolated in his words because many times the sound that they form
serves to blaspheme against me the next one number four I remain isolated in his works
which he uses to kill me number five in his steps number six in his heart which are intent only
on disobeying me and not loving me and not loving what does not sorry and intent on loving what does
not belong to me sorry about that oh how this loneliness weighs on me but my love and my greatness
if I want a different word from magnanimity is so great that more than the sun I continue my course
and in my course I keep investigating whether anyone wants to keep me company in so much loneliness
and as I find this person I form my perennial company in him and I lavish all my graces upon him
this is why I've come to you and it's rare that he uses him for the soul very rare
and considering that he's talking to a woman it's rare as well so just notice that her isn't always
for the soul him is for the soul as well and this is why I've come to you I was tired of so
much loneliness never leave me alone my daughter now she has spent at 14 volumes telling him not
to leave her and now he says knows the other way around don't leave me it's actually the other way
around it's fascinating isn't it and really wow that's very interesting that
I have to say it the most googled word is lonely I have to say it for the recorder yeah yeah
yeah because you see yeah in the world we live in the way people are living leaves them completely
lonely they'll sit around a table but they're all on a gadget and so they're not getting the
loving interaction of human beings oh absolutely absolutely so july the sixth 1922
the blessing which Jesus gave his mother before the passion this is the 5 p.m. hour of the passion
the first hour and one who lives in the divine will is the depository of the sacramental life of
Jesus now it's going to be a very important message that second one I was thinking of Jesus and
accompanying him in the hour of the passion in which he went to his divine mother to ask for her
holy blessing why could he call his mother divine because she was human she was totally human
born of human parents so why does she call her divine yeah it's it's not very wonderful language
it's she's she's a human mother yeah but by grace she's she's well you can't really say that either
the theologians would throw you out if you say that she's divine because she's human but she has a
divine mission that she lives in the divine will okay so it's language that's not completely tidy
here and that's why I'm tripping up on it because if if you're teaching this somebody will trip you
up on it you know and you can't just say well if Jesus said it then it's right louisa is writing
down something afterwards do you know what I mean and she can say something that's not completely
aligned we know what she's saying and we don't misunderstand it but if somebody else misunderstands
it and challenges you you just need to be able to answer it by nature she is by grace yeah she's
completely human by nature yeah which you see it's it's not clear there yeah so he went to his I would
say his mother to ask for her holy blessing and my most sweet Jesus in my interior told me my daughter
before my passion I wanted to bless my mother and be blessed by her however I did not bless only my
mother but all creatures okay so he's blessing all creatures through her she's living in the divine
will and not only those which are animate but those who are inanimate as well to all creation I saw
the creatures weak covered with wounds poor my heart had a throb of sorrow and of tender compassion
and I said poor humanity how decayed you are I want to bless you so that you may rise again from your
decay may my blessing impress in you the triple seal of the power that's the father the wisdom
that's the son and the love that's the Holy Spirit of the three divine persons so power is the father
wisdom the son and love is the Holy Spirit and may it restore your strength heal you and enrich you
and in order to surround you with the defense I bless all things created by me that you may receive
them all blessed by me I bless for you the light the air the water the fire the food so that you may
remain as though immersed and covered in my blessings and now Paul's letter to the Colossians I think
it's chapter one and I it never crossed my head when I was reading this earlier so I haven't got
the verse all things were created through him and for him and Jesus says that everything was made
for us okay absolutely everything so that you may remain as though immersed and covered by my blessings
but since you did not deserve this blessing I wanted to bless my mother who did deserve it
using her as the channel through which my blessing my read you might reach you that's very important
because he's been showing us that he's using louisa to as the channel to get all the divine will acts
out to everybody else and then when we move into the divine will and do our acts he's using us as
a channel to get to everybody else okay so here the mother is the channel so using her as the channel
through which my blessing might reach you and just as my mother requited me with her blessings I want
creatures to requite me with their blessings and alas instead of repaying me with blessings
they repay me with offenses and maladictions therefore my daughter enter into my will and rising
upon the wings of all created things is not a beautiful expression seal all of them with the
blessings that should be given to me and bring the blessings of all to my sorrowful and tender heart
then after I did this louisa said as though to repay me he said my beloved daughter I bless you
in a special way I bless your heart your mind your emotion your word your breath I bless all of you
and everything in you after this louisa said she continued with the hours of the passion
and while she was following the Eucharistic Supper Jesus moved in her interior and with
the tip of his finger he knocked strongly within her interior so much so that she heard him with
her ears which is very unusual and she said to herself what may Jesus want that he's knocking
and he calling me told me it was not enough to knock for you to hear me but also to call you as
to be listened to because we know that in communicating with human beings that the fact that you might
try and get their attention it doesn't guarantee it you might have to call their name and you might
have to do something strongly to get their attention so he's trying to get her attention he said listen
my daughter while I instituted the Eucharistic Supper I called everyone around me I looked at
all generations from the first to the last in order to give my sacramental life to all but not
once but many times as they need corporal food I wanted to constitute myself as food for the souls
it's all john six stuff I just give you the chapter because it's the whole chapter and I felt very
sad in seeing that my sacramental life would be surrounded by scorn by indifference and even by
ruthless death I felt ill I experienced all the grips of death in my sacramental life so harrowing
and repeated then I looked more closely and my I made use of the power of my will and so I called
around me the souls who would live in my will I think this is absolutely incredible so all of us
living in the divine will were called to be around him when he instituted the the Supper it's not
fantastic instituted the the Holy Eucharist oh how happy I felt I felt surrounded by these souls
whom the power of my will kept as though immersed and for whom my will was the center of their lives
now there's the issue again there's your key it has to be that the divine will is the center of the
life I saw my immensity in them and I found myself well defended from all and to them I entrusted
my sacramental life I deposited in them so that they would not only take care of it but repay me
for each consecrated host which with one life of theirs because you know the divine act is a
divine life and this happens naturally because my sacramental life is animated by my divine will
by my eternal will and the life of these souls has the life of my will at its center
therefore when my sacramental life is formed my volition acting in me acts also in them and I feel
their life in my sacramental life they multiply me in each host and I feel I'm given life for life
but it's only the people in the divine will is that not a wonderful description there okay
oh how I rejoiced in seeing you as the first one seeing louisa as the first one
you whom I called in a special way to form your life in my will
I made in you the first deposit of all my sacramental lives and I entrusted you to the power and to the
immensity of the supreme volition that they might render you capable of receiving this deposit
from that time you were present to me and I constituted you as the depository of my sacramental life
and watch this now and in you all other souls who would live in my divine will
I gave you primacy over everything and with reason because my will is subject to no one
even over the apostles and the priests in fact if they consecrate me they do not however remain
as life together with me on the contrary they leave me alone and forgotten not caring about me
while these souls who would live within my own life inseparable from me now those who live in the
divine will Jesus says are inseparable from him this is why I love you so much it is my very will
that I love in you isn't that fantastic it is my very will that I love in you
so a big VIP on July the 10th 1922 living in the divine will is to repeat the real life
of Jesus you need to you need to sort of ring the word real people will think this is some kind of
airy fairy mystical up the air stuff and he says no it's my real life that you're living not only
in the soul but also in the body so if we're living his real life in the body you have a small
incarnation incarnation means in the body okay and we say the divine word became incarnate that
means he took on the body so if he is living his real life not only in our souls but in our bodies
then it means this is the return of Christ this is his return to the earth now if you listen to the
evangelicals and people like that on the internet he's got to come back physically there's going to
be a city dropping down from heaven that he's going to live in and he's going to rain for a thousand
years physically upon the earth now these people claim that they are the experts in scripture and
the weak Catholics know nothing about it and they're completely wrong because one of the most basic
statements instead of a statement it's a teaching in scripture old and new testament is that God
never repeats himself ever he's a creator he never repeats himself and when God is going to do
something he will do something new you read it in in Isaiah you read it in Jeremiah you read it in
other prophets you read it in the New Testament behold I am going to do something new and Isaiah
is very strong on that and so when Jesus came in the incarnation two thousand years ago he managed
to fulfill most of the prophecies that were made about him there's still a few to be fulfilled he
managed to fulfill most of the prophecies that was given about him and yet nobody would accept that
this was the fulfillment they would just wouldn't accept that a Galilean from absolutely nowhere
like Nazareth who didn't even have the right connections and didn't have the right address
and didn't have the right education it didn't have the blah blah blah that couldn't be it no no no
absolutely no and so they they pitted their own opinion against what God does it's going to be
exactly the same with the next coming of Christ he's going to come in people who live in the divine
will and they won't accept it it'll be exactly the same as before they won't accept it human beings
don't and yet he will have fulfilled what he said okay it's it's it's an amazing thing
so continue in my usual state I felt my beloved Jesus in my interior but so real is the bit you
need to underline that first I would feel him squeeze my heart so tightly as to make me suffer
and then he would clasp my arms around his neck to the point of suffocating me and then he would
sit on my heart it's bitter I know it's a sense of humor what assuming an heir of dominion and
command and I would feel as though annihilated and then risen again to new life under his command
but who can say what he did in my interior and what I felt I believe it's better to pass over
in silence in other words she's not able to say it okay but while I was feeling his watch this now
his real presence in my interior he told me my daughter rise rise more because you see the
spiritual life even before you get to the divine will is arising from the dead that's actually what
it is well when you're talking about the spiritual life as in the divine will then you have arising
to a level that others couldn't even imagine rise he said rise more what's so high as to reach the
womb of my divinity your life will be among the three divine persons that means you live a heavenly
life on the earth see in order to make you reach this point I formed my life in you I enclosed my
eternal volition in whatever you do and there it flows in a marvelous and surprising way
meaning there's no way Louisa could understand it and there is no way the week would understand
it either I think it's in volume 24 that he says that it's beyond the comprehension of the human
mind to actually grasp the fullness of divine will so no matter what we do we're only limping at it
yeah and the fact that he has said it is terribly important yeah because some people
want to shy back and not share it with us because they don't understand it fully
and but I taught science in schools without having understood everything about science
you just were a couple of steps ahead of the students that was out hopefully
unless one of them was more brilliant than yourself it wasn't hard
absolutely but spiritually we're inclined to hold back just because we don't understand everything
and it's it's wrong because if you have the courage to step out on the water
and try to share it the Lord will give you the words and he will give you the answers I have found
this last Thursday just give you an example we were reading a bit in volume one about
Louisa receiving this milk from the Lord you know and I said to the group look I've shared this
many times I said and I don't understand the milk all I can tell you is that other saints
and mystics have had the same experience and I just finished it and I said always just told me
what it is and I explained to them I said this is what it is but it was because I was
simple enough to actually acknowledge that I didn't know
that he actually gave it to me and you know what he said he said because he said you get
everything from the family I told you that he said a child the first thing it does it goes to
its mother's breast and receives life through milk it actually receives its mother's life
and everything is in that milk in exactly the proportion that is required for this little life
he said when I am feeding people directly they're feeding from the divine breast and I give them
everything as well and they will understand the symbol and I thought yeah some of us are
taken off not it was interesting but I'd never been able to explain it before because I was
waiting for some theologian to give some fanciful explanation instead of that the Lord gave something
that's so simple everybody can understand it yes but we also yeah we also have to courageously
step out in front of others when we're teaching and allow the Lord to give you the enlightenment
because they were all thrilled when I said he's just explained it to me and it meant more to them
that I got it in front of them then if I came and I had it all organized do you know what I mean
it actually did mean more and they just said no this is wonderful because they've never experienced
anything like that before and I'm saying that to encourage you who are teaching that's actually
terribly important to just be open up I call it walking on water you know and after a while you
don't look at the water you just look at the Lord and when Peter looked at the Lord he walked when
he stopped looking at me he sank and we know those words but to know the reality of walking on water
is wonderful okay so Jesus saying to her I formed my life in you I enclosed my eternal volition in
whatever you do and there it flows in a marvelous and surprising way and my volition is acting in
you in a continuous immediate act look at the immediate act in whatever you're doing at this moment
my volition is operating in that so that's in my speaking and in your writing at this moment and
also your thinking and all the rest of it now after I have formed my life in you while my will acting
in you in your act your will has remained soaked transfused in such a way that my volition possesses
a life upon the earth okay so in the next section we're going to have the inauguration of the era of
the new and divine holiness spoken about now it is necessary that you rise and carry with you
my life and my will so that my volition of the earth and that of heaven may fuse together
and you may live for some time in the womb of the divinity where your volition will be acting in
mine in order to expand it as much as a creature can be capable of then you will descend again upon
the earth bringing the power and the tragedies of my will in such a way that the creatures will
be shaken they will open their eyes and many will know what it means to live in my will
to live in the likeness of their creator now it's very important to use this new language
that living in the divine will is living in the likeness of our creator that's what he's saying
this will be the beginning of the coming of my kingdom upon earth and of the final fulfillment
of my will so the beginning of the new era and that is that there's a will on earth operating
absolutely with the will in heaven so heaven and earth are joined together and therefore that the
new era can begin the in the next paragraph it says that we have to become another little
incarnation and if you use the word incarnation put inverted commas okay so that neither you
nor anybody else will misunderstand what we're saying do you think that living in my will is
something trivial there is nothing that equals it nor sanctity that matches it it is the real
life not a fantastic one as some may imagine and this life of mine is not only in the soul but
also in the body because he's set up above it's in your every immediate act didn't he say that okay
I'm I'm with you in your continuous immediate act but do you know how this life of mine is formed
my eternal will is that of the soul and my heartbeat palpitating in her heart forms my conception
her love her pains and all her acts done in my will form my humanity and make me grow so much
that I cannot remain hidden nor can she help feeling me don't you feel me alive in your interior
this is why I told you that the sanctity of living in my will cannot be matched by anything
else all other sanctities are like little lights while it will be the great sun transfused in the
creator now that's about saying it's straight isn't it so the next the last paragraph of this
section is to feel Jesus in your interior one of the definitions that's given for contemplation
is that a person becomes aware of God all the time and so they enter into that awareness more
and more deeply okay now it's something different that's being said here it's it's it's it's beyond
just a spiritual awareness now in order to obey and with great reluctance louisa says
I will say how I feel Jesus in my interior because he said don't you feel me I feel him
at the place of my heart so the center of my being almost in an invisible way and I hear him
praying and many times I hear him with the ears of my body and I pray together with him
okay now she has explained this back in volume one the ways that she that Jesus communicates with her
and when suffering he makes me hear his interrupted and labored breath because she
often says that in the hours of the passion okay and I feel it in my breathing so much so that I
am forced to pant together with him and since all creatures are contained in him I feel his breath
diffusing as life in all human motions and breaths and I diffuse together with him because in the
divine will you're present wherever the divine will is present then I feel him moan and agonize
or I feel him move his arms and stretch them within mine when sleeping my interior remains
in deep silence but who can say everything Jesus alone can say what he operates in me and I don't
have adequate words to manifest it I did it only to obey with the highest torment of my soul and
for fear that my Jesus might be displeased because he tolerates me as long as obedience
does not command me but if obedience commands only the fiat is left to me otherwise he would
annihilate me isn't that very interesting and I hope that everything will be for his glory and
to my confusion okay notice that if I disobey he would annihilate me okay this is her shocking
awareness that it is the divinity that is within her okay and while the divinity is within her
there is her own nothingness so that's why she she could say after all this intimacy and all this
privilege and everything she could say but if I don't obey he could annihilate me so we leave
it there for tonight.